here's what would happen if seeds could  grow in your stomach  in a world where seeds could easily grow  in your stomach the demand for seedless  fruits and vegetables would skyrocket  seeds need warmth moisture and oxygen to  germinate and you'll find all of that in  your stomach hydrochloric acid would  have no trouble dissolving a seeds  protective coating and that would allow  the seed to absorb water and start to  grow  the seed would then move on to your  duodenum where its first sprouts could  grow if they were tough enough to  survive your intestinal juices  the seed might also steal some of the  nutrients you're trying to digest  and if it were able to get enough  nutrients the plant might even start to  grow flowers and produce fruit hopefully  you would have gone to the hospital long  before this point because with branches  flowers and fruit growing inside you the  pain would be unbearable luckily we  don't live in a world where this is a  risk but